nightshades are a huge family of plants
many which we eat like potatoes tomatoes
peppers and eggplants some like
tomatillos and ground cherries have a
papery structure that grows around the
fruit it forms an air pocket that might
help the seeds disperse like a little
life raft this family comes from South
America where its fossil origins aren't
well known previously it was thought
that tomatillos and ground cherries
evolved fairly recently at the time the
Andes rose but new fossils that look
just like those wrapped up fruits were
recently described by researchers these
fossils prove that these plants were
around at a much earlier time than
anyone thought when South America was
still very close to hard to cut in
Australia and even southern South
America where the fossils were found was
warm and wet it also means these plants
evolved not just in South America but
likely in Antarctica too before it froze
over those are totally different
evolutionary conditions which makes you
wonder what else don't we know about our
favorite foods
[Music]